it's enough if I if I remember us that
the human being is an animal
I agree okay that was that was all what
I wanted to say
if you
or no
and that means
in the human being
in a critical situation
uh will be always aggressive
and
to be able uh torture his enemy
and okay in Bali we're fantastic Sun uh
shined and so on on the politic level
political level can happen good things
and it it it gives you some some some
optimism or happiness or some some way
out
but the human being is an animal
yeah sorry
we're a special kind of animal yes we
have a soul and a spirit and we have a
reason and if we use these things we
ought to be able to do better than uh no
no Mr Charlotte no
no no no we don't agree yeah the human
being the human beings the human being
belongs to the to the nature and the
nature doesn't know the piece for
example so I think intelligence is
important
um
the ability to think things through to
to reason
but this emphasis we've had in the
discussion at various points on the
animal nature of humankind I also think
is important
um
I think we've tended to think of animal
instincts in terms of you know if you're
attacked you you protect yourself that's
an animal Instinct but of course it's
also an animal instinct to nurture and
to take care of people and if we can
combine intelligence with that side of
animality
then we might just avoid catastrophe